let's talk about something we've
discussed kind of anecdotally before but
not not big picture um the tsa
says that they have confiscated a record
number of firearms from
airline passengers at airports this year
and you might be shocked to know that
only some of those confiscated firearms
belonged to republican congressman
madison cawthorne uh so only a partial
joke there he actually did get caught
trying to
um bring a bring a firearm on board uh
getting it through secure trying to get
it through security um just a few months
ago let's discuss the data passengers
are bringing a record number of guns to
the airport tsa says airline passengers
are bringing guns to the airport in
numbers never seen before and it is a
quote huge problem
security and law enforcement officials
are at the same time dealing with an
unprecedented surge in belligerent
passengers straining the systems
designed to designed to keep air travel
safe
we've had more incidences
where don't they mean incidents we've
had many we've had many more incidences
where there are passenger disturbances
both in checkpoints and onboard aircraft
that makes it more important that there
are no guns involved says tsa
administrator david pokowski
tsa reports catching 4 650 firearms at
checkpoints in the first 10 months of
the year a majority of which were loaded
folks loaded firearms in airports that
surpasses the full-year record of 4432
from 2019 so we've still got the rest of
october
um as well as november and december and
we're already several hundred firearms
beyond the record
with 11 weeks left in the year including
the busy thanksgiving and christmas
seasons the number will reflect an
american population that is increasingly
armed i think more people are carrying
weapons just generally across the
country and then whatever is happening
across the country we see reflected in
our checkpoints as a passenger i don't
want another passenger flying with me
with a gun in their possession
yeah
the agency is also finding guns at a
faster rate than it has ever experienced
during the lows of air travel during the
pandemic in 2020 transportation security
officers confiscated a gun from about 10
passengers every 1 million this year
they're finding 11 armed passengers in
every 1 million eighty percent eighty
percent of the firearms
were found
loaded
no checkpoint
no airport is immune from having
passengers try to carry guns through the
checkpoint it does occur occur more
frequently in again the states where gun
carriage is at a higher rate compared to
other states you know there are people
who react to these stories and in fact
republican congressman madison cawthorne
said exactly this when he was caught
the explanation was the justification
was it was an honest mistake
i didn't realize that the gun was in my
carry-on
that is
negligent action
if you don't know one what are the main
things about firearms
uh keep them unloaded
keep them safely stored and know where
they are
if you believe your gun is unloaded at
home
or unloaded
in your checked baggage and it's
actually loaded in your carry-on
that is negligence and you shouldn't
even have that firearm
um the the justification the excuse that
they use
is actually something for which they
should have the ability to have that
firearm removed if you can't keep track
of where your loaded firearms are you
don't have any business owning a gun
aside from anybody's views about the
second amendment or background checks or
whatever when you say oops
i didn't think the gun was in my
carry-on then you didn't know where it
was and that's negligence and it's
irresponsible gun ownership
not knowing where your gun is
um and it's a frequently used excuse but
it's not really an excuse it should
actually make us say whoa we should
we've got to look into that more
the article goes on to say
firearm fines by tsa workers create an
inconvenience for flyers during a time
when more people are looking to travel
again yeah it's more than an
inconvenience it's actually a sort of an
existential threat
firearms 80 loaded
gun discovery's slow checkpoint lines
trigger a local or airport police
response airline officials meanwhile are
asking airport police to be proactive
about spotting intoxicated or otherwise
agitated passengers who may spark an
in-flight disturbance yeah we've talked
about this as well uh those unruly
passengers are also at previously unseen
levels it's sort of like a uh
pandemic induced psychosis that we're
seeing uh it
it's it's wild what is happening at
airports
i've how many times have i flown during
the pandemic i guess three round-trip
flights
and all of the stuff i saw at the u.s
airports part of it was at international
airports everything i saw at us airports
um
there was wacky behavior wacky behavior
and this is this is by the way beyond
just people playing fast and loose with
the mask rules like holding a glass the
entire flight
to be in the process of drinking and
keeping their mask down you know stuff
like that
i'm talking about just
belligerent people
drunk people loud people people
screaming um it's
it's not good it's not good what's going
on and certainly adding firearms to that
mix would only make it much much worse
one of our sponsors is cometeer coffee
the world's first frozen coffee i've
been very impressed with the coffee i've
had from cometier cometeer sources their
beans from some of the world's best
locally owned specialty roasters and the
cometer team has developed their own way
of protecting the freshness and aroma of
the coffee by taking its concentrated
liquid form and flash freezing it so it
keeps those original flavors and nuances
comets here comes to you frozen you just
add hot water or for iced coffee you
just melt it you can use it to make a
ton of different hot and cold coffee
drinks the way they lock in the flavor
like this you really can taste it it
tastes fresh i've been getting a ton of
enjoyment out of cometier they've got a
great variety of coffees it's delicious
the way you make it is super convenient
and you'll get twenty dollars off when
you go to
cometier.com
pacman the link is underneath this video